les mecs qui font les pubs à la télé
soit ils sont complètement drogué soit
ils viennent d'un monde parallèle
je vois que ça je crois que les pubs
c'est le truc le plus éloigné de la
réalité
non
dans les pubs bonjour je suis votre
nouvelle voisine on s'est vu l'autre
jour ah oui c'est vrai je vois que vous
avez un peu de gâteau il est délicieux
non merci je crois que c'est un peu trop
pour moi je crois que je préférais là
dans la vie je sortais de chez moi et je
crois que je préférais le team venant au
dégage j'appelle les flics hockey non
j'avais acquis n'importe quoi mais c'est
mon bâton qui s'est conclue norme
pendant les pubs excusez moi pensez vous
que vos dents sans vraiment propre oui
bien sûr vérifions ça regardez des
bactéries mais je me suis brosser les
dents ce matin pas avec colgate total
dans la vie c'est moi c'est ce que je
cherchais dans la broye en plus ces
pompes ce que j'ai dans stahl et ton cul
l'épreuve du coup il va ta cravate de
merde dans les pubs qui veut savoir si
tu vas retourner avec ton mec en bois ex
aux 8 12 ou dont la vie elle pense
toujours à toi elle va revenir c'est
sûre à 200%
elle est morte dans les pubs ça commence
par des démangeaisons et des sensations
de brûlure et savez vous ce que c'est ce
sont des mycoses vaginales
non je ne veux pas me cacher dans la vie
tu sais j'ai des mycoses vaginales
mais je veux pas me cacher d'ailleurs ça
me gratte
mais je me retiens mais tu sais ça ça
peut arriver à tout le monde attend mais
ça mérite vraiment dans les pubs
vive et of fixation béton dans la vie
moi je pencherais un peu fragilisé avec
la 4g c'est l'accès à tout internet en
un instant j'y vais non non a laissé la
4g redit que j'y vais dans les pubs
dans la vie dans les pubs sanex nature
protect efficacité naturelle dans la vie
cemex nature protect dans les pubs dans
la vie dans les pubs
moi j'aime ma banque dans la vie moi je
prends pas les couilles de ma banque
très pure je rêve d'une banque à vis le
rêve d'une banque
les [ __ ] fort de la révère double
cheese
oui abonne toi